while the Georgia Senate race remains
neck and neck potentially heads to a
runoff and Arizona continues to make a
mockery of our electoral process the
rest of the country has finished
selecting its politicians for this cycle
the night
seems like I hope it will technically be
a win for Republicans sort of actually
remains to be seen
either way even if Republicans do take
the house even if Republicans do take
the Senate given the lofty Ambitions of
the GOP the modest pickups have felt
more like a loss
but we won't be talking about that for
very long because even though the
Maricopa County voting machines haven't
even cooled off yet the GOP has already
moved on to the race for 2024.
the election is dead long live the
election I'm Michael Knowles it's the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Aaron Levitt
who says the Dems are telling us that
they have managed us so well that we the
richest country in the world can now
afford canned pasta yes not a great
election pitch and yet the Dems did
pretty well though the man who made that
that claim uh the man who advised people
who are struggling in Biden's economy to
just go eat Chef Boyardee that guy did
lose his job last night and we'll get to
that because I'm very excited about that
race there's still some big wins there's
still some some great stories from
election night but it was not the total
bloodbath that a lot of people had been
expecting and and that means that you're
gonna still have more Democrat control
over the country than we had hoped for
and you're going to have more of your
political opponents prying into all the
things you're doing and it's why you
need to use a VPN that's why you got to
check out it expressvpn right now head
on over to expressvpn.com Knowles do you
know what big Tech and our corrupt big
government have in common they both want
to silence any dissenting voices into
submission let's say that you're a gun
owner you want to talk on social media
about the right to keep and bear arms
Second Amendment your post will probably
be flagged by a Content moderator and
you'll end up on some government watch
list to fight back against having your
voice censored by both big Tech and big
government I recommend expressvpn big
Tech tracks everything you do online
and it matches your activity to your
identity by using your device's unique
IP address when I use expressvpn
big Tech cannot see my IP address making
me virtually Anonymous plus expressvpn
encrypts 100 of my internet data to
protect me from hackers and
eavesdroppers expressvpn is by far the
best VPN I have tried but you don't have
to take my word for it
expressvpn is the number one rated VPN
by CNET Business Insider and countless
other Tech Publications what I love most
about expressvpn is how easy it is to
use the app has just one button you
click it and all your online activity is
protected stop letting big Tech end our
corrupt big government censor and track
you protect yourself at expressvpn.com
Knowles that's
expresvpn.com Knowles to get three
months free expressvpn.com Knowles
so there was good news last night there
was I don't want to be one of these
conservatives who is just constantly
catastrophizing everything and saying
that the sky is falling down there was
good news JD Vance beats Tim Ryan in
Ohio an important senate senate seat
this race had been kind of close uh JD
Vance is a new right kind of candidate
he's a candidate who's running not just
on the old tired you know tax cuts and
ignore the culture kind of issues but JD
Vance is running on explicitly a pro
family policy he's uh running on an
anti-immigration platform not just
anti-legal immigration but restricting
all immigration so he's running a very
conservative
kind of trumpy kind of populist kind of
nationalist kind of whatever issue you
want to call it not the old Rhino
establishment kind of campaign and that
was a big win because Tim Ryan the
Democrat had positioned himself as a as
a working man's Democrat you know I'm
not one of these latte sipping liberals
I'm uh I'm a blue-collar kind of
democrat and it was completely
disingenuous coming from Tim Ryan but
the pitch seemed to be kind of working
on the campaign Trail okay JD wins in
Ohio they say as goes Ohio so goes the
nation so that was good stuff
uh bad news we just got out of Michigan
uh Whitmer this awful leftist governor
in Michigan she beat Tudor Dixon who had
made a real play for Michigan uh good
seemed like a decent Republican
candidate but just could not go the
distance so Democrats win their uh Kathy
hokel in New York beats lizelden the
Republican I don't want to beat up on
Lee zeldin too much Lee zeldon ran a New
York Republican kind of campaign he's
not some rock ribbed right-wing
conservative but he put up the most
credible
campaign the most credible threat to
Democrat power in New York since George
Pataki it was a really impressive
campaign he got pretty close he lost in
the end Kathy hokel wins the Democrats
win
too bad uh The Big Race that people are
looking at is Herschel Walker versus
Raphael Warnock right now that is in a
complete Dead Heat neither candidate as
of some minutes before this show began
today neither candidate had over 50
percent which means that that race is
likely headed to a runoff it's a little
frustrating too
because the libertarian candidate there
did act as a spoiler and even just the
one to two percent that the libertarian
candidate got would be enough to have
put Herschel Walker over the line but
Herschel Walker had problems as a
candidate so it could be headed to a
runoff if that race goes to a runoff
probably doesn't bode very well for
Herschel Walker because Herschel Walker
was riding I think he hoped National
political headwinds for the Republicans
and was riding on Governor Kemp's
coattails uh Governor Brian Kemp won so
that's an important race uh but for
Herschel if it's just him just versus
Warnock knowing also that Democrats are
much better at runoff type races that's
not great news
now I mentioned Brian Kemp this was
fabulous news so Brian Kemp absolutely
destroys
the
Governor Pretender in Exile uh Stacy
Abrams the president of the universe
according to Star Trek Stacey Abrams has
never really conceded her gubernatorial
loss in 2018 and she just got completely
destroyed with facts and logic and votes
last night it was so bad that she had to
concede this is a woman who a lot of us
thought maybe she just won't concede she
still hasn't conceded her race from four
years ago well she had to concede this
time it was just so bad he beat her 53.5
percent to 45.8 percent so you can't
really claim voter fraud in that in that
kind of a race especially when the
Democrat loses and the Democrats are the
ones who are known for their Shenanigans
so she lost and she she's conceited and
then another totally satisfying race
this was so delicious this was so
delectable
Beto O'Rourke just got
btfode I mean just got absolutely blown
out of the water and uh the race was
55.6 to 43.1 percent uh devastating
Republicans are just being absolutely
merciless in their mockery of him which
we will get to a little bit later on in
the show but but really really good news
there uh and then there were just some
some losses and one of the most painful
losses for a lot of people I think is
the Pennsylvania Senate race Dr Oz loses
to John fetterman here's fetterman's
victory speech
yeah I uh I'm I'm not really sure really
what to say right now my goodness
[Applause]
I am
yeah
[Applause]
yeah I mean uh
all right
so I am
I'm so humbled thank you so much really
thank you thank you
John fetterman I am not really sure what
to say right now truer words have never
been spoken by a Victorious Senate
candidate now this one did not surprise
me this surprised a lot of Republicans
didn't surprise me I was predicting
fetterman would win going into the
election uh that's because well one it's
because Philadelphia is known for some
Shenanigans especially in close races
but even more than that because Dr Oz
was a terrible candidate and I've made
no bones about that fact I think he's
just awful I think he's a total loser
and so I'm not surprised that he lost
uh and it was it was unfortunate that he
was the nominee and then he lost to a
man who had an absolutely horrible
record no professional accomplishments
in his life a radical vision for the
country and brain damage such that he
couldn't even really campaign
nevertheless he won and that's a real
gut punch for Republicans now again I
don't think the fact that Republicans
lost to a guy with brain damage as is
the headline right now I don't think
that's actually the big issue here
okay because if it were me if I were a
Pennsylvania voter and it were reversed
and it was the Republican who'd had some
health problem and he wasn't really
functioning he wasn't on the campaign
Trail versus some articulate Democrat I
would still vote for the Republican I
don't really care I want the Senate
majority I want a guy who's going to
reliably vote for the right stuff and so
I I'm not really surprised by all that
the health issue it doesn't doesn't bug
me nearly as much as his just insane
policy agenda now I mentioned this
question of Fraud and irregularities and
shenanigans and all of that I don't
think Republicans can blame these losses
on voter fraud because we did get most
of the results last night relatively
quickly now you might still say there's
a big problem with widespread mail-in
voting I do think that's a problem I do
think that's open to abuse I do think
there's a problem with ballot harvesting
I do think there's a problem with early
voting I think all of these things are
absolutely awful and have no place in a
a stable sacred democracy that we are
supposed to be and I do think it opens
up the possibility of fraud that's not
my crazy conspiratorial view that's the
view of Barack Obama That's the view of
basically everybody with two brain cells
to rub together so I yeah that's all a
problem but we did get most of the
results last night and so there are
other problems there are other political
problems why did the Republicans not do
nearly as well as we were supposed to
we'll get into that in terms of the
issues where the places where fraud
really may have been a problem
the the top of that list is Maricopa
County
uh Maricopa County
early in the day at you know we're
talking about a county that had problems
in 2020 in a state that was hotly
contested in 2020 there were lots of
questions about voter integrity
and early in the day
one-fifth of the voting machines in
Maricopa County
malfunctioned here's a poll worker
explaining what happened
so I pulled my ballot in but so it
didn't gotten this read but then what
was happening
put it in there yeah and tonight a
Republican and a Democrat will sit and
go through all of the misread ballots
all over the county and count them and
it will get counted okay okay and then
both machines were not working yeah no
nothing to work in the last half hour
thank you nothing's working for the last
half hour sounds like the people who not
that nice sounding lady but the people
who set up those machines the people
whose only job it was to run that
election sounds like uh probably Arizona
should have hired some better people for
that when you want to hire better people
for your Enterprise you got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now head on over to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles are you hiring
what type of role are you hiring for
maybe you need to hire someone who can
wear many hats which can be very
difficult or maybe you have a simple
position to fill but it's taking forever
to find someone who's a great fit for
your company whether you need to hire a
civil engineer in New York a pediatric
nurse in Nebraska or an attorney in
Colorado ZipRecruiter can help you you
find qualified candidates fast now you
can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com
Knowles from accountant to zoologist and
everything in between zip recruiters
matching technology finds people with
the right experience for your job and
presents them to you then you can invite
your top choices to apply ZipRecruiter
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
try it now for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com Knowles
that is ziprecruiter.com
k-n-o-w-l-e-s ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
lots of problems in Maricopa County some
of the the poll workers made it sound
even dodgier take a listen
so what happens is we have two
tabulators one of the tabulators is not
working okay the other tabulator is
taking about 75 successful so 25 of them
are being misread and it couldn't be a
printer issue
um or it could be the tabulator itself
so when it's misread you have an option
to put it into what's called box three
and it gets red whether it goes downtown
and gets threaded manually or whether it
gets reset into our tablet you don't
want to adjudicate get red okay so no
one's trying to
deceive anyway of course not not on
Election Day that would never happen
right no that would never happen so so
choices are you know you guys
I'll come back see here this poll worker
and he says no listen yeah it's true a
huge number of these voting machines
just don't work for some reason in this
hotly contested County and in a swing
state in a oopsie Daisy but no one's
trying to deceive anyone and you hear
the guy filming he says oh yeah right
yeah no one's ever trying to deceive
anyone on Election Day
which which
brings me to this question of election
denial and questioning the Integrity of
our elections there there has been this
ironic attack from Democrats since 2020.
the the attack of the election denier
you're an election denier and they use
that phrase because it reminds people of
Holocaust denier
the idea the the event denier formula is
meant to direct your attention to
Holocaust denier that's why they
sometimes do it with climate denier as
well and so it's just a a disgusting
sort of a smear but and it's ironic of
course because Democrats have been
denying elections a lot longer and in
much greater numbers than the
Republicans have but now are we really
to believe that there are no questions
ever on Election Day that no one ever
tries to deceive anyone on Election Day
what are you talking about everyone is
trying to deceive everyone on Election
Day that's why we have poll Watchers
that's why we have we had such a rule
serious rules in place to prevent this
kind of stuff from happening
the conspiracy theory is not election
denial the conspiracy theory is election
denial denial or election fraud denial
that's the conspiracy theory because
there has been fraud there have been
Shenanigans in every election going back
at least to Pericles and probably much
further back than that that's why we
need rules in place to prevent this sort
of stuff from happening
you you hear the the guys come out who
are in charge of this
in Maricopa County and they just sound
absolutely feckless they say yeah
there's some problems don't worry we're
working on it
we had all 223 vote centers have opened
we've already had over 45 000 people who
have checked in and and already voted
today we did want to come out and
discuss one issue that's going on out
there in about 20 percent of the vote
centers again we have 223 vote centers
across the county in about 20 percent of
those uh when people will go and they
try and run the ballot through this
tabulator maybe one out of every five or
so of those ballots they're not going
through
so it's yeah it's you know it's not like
everything's going great it's just that
one out of five votes are not being
counted properly so what's the solution
to that the solution as this guy
explains and it's funny his name is Bill
Gates I assume no relation but for those
who are a little more skeptical of the
established powers that be uh that's
kind of a funny coincidence lots of
coincidences and uh so anyway this guy
says okay if you're if your ballot's not
being printed or being uh processed
correctly then here you go just put it
in this random box
we've got about 20 of the locations out
there where there's an issue with the
tabulator where some of the ballots that
after people have voted them they try
and run them through the tabulator and
they're not going through but the good
thing is is we do first of all we're
trying to fix this problem as quickly as
possible and we also have a redundancy
in place if you can't put the ballot in
the tabulator then you can simply place
it here in where you the see the number
three and this is a secure box where
those ballots will be kept for later
this evening or we'll bring them in here
to Central count to tabulate them so
this would function much like early
voting functions and there we go I bet
it will I bet it will this will function
this redundancy that's in place for 20
percent what an implausibly high number
of the of the ballots in Maricopa County
this will function largely as early
voting right I'm sure it will
and the reason that Republicans are
crying foul over this is because early
voting one is more open to fraud than
same-day voting than proper register get
the count by the end of the night voting
and because
that mail and mail-in voting and early
voting both favor Democrats so I I have
no doubt that that's how the redundancy
would function but that that's a big
problem Carrie Lake who was looking
great the Republican candidate for
governor Arizona she was looking great
early yesterday and now it's very
unclear if she will win
Carrie Lake decided to go vote in a
liberal Precinct she said no problems
there
we switched from a republican area to
vote we came right down into the heart
of liberal Phoenix
[Music]
because we wanted to make sure that we
had good machines and guess what they've
had zero problems with their machines
today not one machine spit out a ballot
here today
not one in a very liberal area so we
were right to come about in a liberal
area
they gotta fix this problem this is
incompetency I hope it's not malice but
we're going to fix it we're gonna win
and when we win there's going to be come
to Jesus for elections in Arizona
there's going to be a come to Jesus so I
hope Carrie like wins but the point
she's raising here is yeah it's one in
five uh poll poll centers pole machines
in Maricopa County but it's not evenly
distributed her claim at least again we
don't know we're kind of in the fog of
War on this election night but her claim
is that
the liberal precincts did not have the
problems it was the conservative
precincts that did
which would explain how Maricopa County
which is pretty liberal
would be the epicenter of some of these
problems
Well yeah if it's only affecting the
conservative precincts not the liberal
ones again that's an if based on what
Gary lake is saying
then that seems a little strange
one place where there was no ambiguity
this was the bright spot of the night
Ron DeSantis absolutely destroyed in
Florida he destroyed his opponent
Charlie Christ Rhonda Santos won
re-election 59.4 percent to 39.9 percent
Ron DeSantis barely won his first
election as governor of Florida he
absolutely crushed it in his re-election
uh why did that happen well in part
let's not forget he did tighten up
election laws I I don't think that's the
chief reason that's part of it why did
it because he's been a great governor of
Florida and everybody loves the guy down
there and he just led the way in the
nation especially among the governors on
covid and on education and on dealing
with woke corporations and he's just
been a fabulous fabulous governor and so
as a result of this last night Ron
DeSantis has a very credible case to run
against Donald Trump for president going
into last night
a lot of people would not have said that
it would have said Donald Trump is so
far up in the polls it's 70 plus
DeSantis is somewhere around 10
it's just if Trump decides he's running
he clears the field no one can
incredibly run against him after last
night especially where a lot of trump
endorsed candidates have did not do very
well
for whatever reason uh and and Ron
DeSantis not only destroyed in his
re-election campaign but really brought
Florida very firmly into the Republican
camp
Rhonda Santos now could very credibly
come out even if Donald Trump announces
that he's running for president next
week and it's I think unclear that he
will do that he had implied that he
would do that but after last night after
the Republicans did not do nearly as
well as we thought we would it's unclear
if he will do that but even if he does
Ron DeSantis I think could announce a
run against him and he could have
you could have a very serious campaign
and if Ron DeSantis runs on his record
runs on the election wins in Florida
runs on the underperformance of the
Republicans nationally particularly some
of the Trump endorsed candidates that's
a good case now there's one candidate in
Florida uh who is a Senate candidate
there Republican who Trump did not
endorse who Ron DeSantis did endorse and
that candidate lost so some people are
going to say well look it's not just the
Trump's endorsements weren't that great
but DeSantis endorsements Nationwide
that one guy didn't do that well
and on the rest DeSantis and Trump were
basically agreed okay yeah I just think
that gets wiped away when you look at
the massive shift of Voters to the
Republican party in Florida now again is
that all thanks to DeSantis is part of
that thanks to the coronavirus it's part
of that thanks to the lockdowns and
people voting with their feet so you
just see an influx of Republicans into
Florida now is that thanks to Rhonda
Sanders because Rhonda Sanders
discovering in a good way there's a
little bit of a chicken and an egg here
but the upshot of all of it is we now
have now that the 2022 midterms are over
we now have a much much more competitive
2024 Republican presidential primary
than we did two days ago
how is Donald Trump reacting to the much
more competitive Republican presidential
primary because Ron DeSantis did so well
in Florida
he is threatening him
so uh Trump comes out
says in an interview with Fox News
digital quote
DeSantis shouldn't run you know I don't
I don't think he should run it would not
go very well for him and then he says
this is a direct quote I would tell you
things about him that won't be very
flattering I know more about him than
anybody other than perhaps his wife
so there's a threat
Trump is and I don't think it's an idol
threat I bet the Trump campaign has
pretty good Oppo research on DeSantis
because DeSantis has been the chief
threat to Trump on the right for months
now or more than months even over a year
now and so I'm sure he's got some Oppo
on it what is the what is the threat
here
the threat here seems to me
Ron DeSantis I'm going to say that
you've got woman problems right I think
that's why he includes that line other
than perhaps your wife
and that's one of the lowest hanging
fruits in politics is to accuse someone
of having an affair or whatever
obviously Trump has been accused of this
many times and it was an issue in the
2016 campaign so I think that's what
he's saying he said I got a lot of dirty
laundry on you now maybe he's Trump is
also insinuating I've got
you know more political scandals or I've
got Financial scandals or I've got this
or I've got that but I think from this
threat here
Trump is clearly insinuating that he's
got a sex scandal up his sleeve now is
Trump bluffing Trump has bluffed many
times before
but what you can see is this is starting
to get nasty now all the nastiness is
coming from Trump you'll notice DeSantis
is not attacking Donald Trump at all
which does seem to suggest that DeSantis
is feeling very confident right now
Trump is feeling less confident the fact
that Trump attacked DeSantis the other
day called him Rhonda sanctimonious
was evidence I think
of trump feeling a little insecure here
because Trump whatever you want to say
about his attacks and they can be brutal
and they've destroyed people
Trump to my knowledge has never started
a fight
someone always attacks them first and it
might just be a mild offense
and then Trump comes in and collabores
them
but Trump as a rule does not really seem
to attack first
in the case of DeSantis he attacks first
why because I think he realizes he's got
a sideline Ron because Ron right now has
a ton of momentum and coming out of
these midterms he's got a ton of
momentum again though
everybody seems to be going into Camp so
I'm still a trump guy well I'm uh I
Ronda Santos is the greatest thing since
sliced bread every other Republican's
got to go away and the reason we were
asked last night on Backstage Trump were
de Santa who do you pick
and everyone's going around and they say
I'm you know I guess in that case it was
uniformly DeSantis but they said I'm and
we're I'm totally committed and
basically sign me up for the campaign
and it got to me and I said guys
one I don't make endorsements in
primaries as a general rule okay but two
it's 2022.
at this time
in the 2012 election cycle do you know
who the Front Runners were
Mitch Daniels and Haley Barber and Bobby
Jindal okay
do you know I mean they were the ones
who were being talked about
in 2016 who were the Front Runners
wasn't Trump what wasn't Cruz
what it was it was the guys who were
some of the first ones out and so I just
think
I love Trump I'm not willing to throw
him under the bus
not willing to trash him and blame every
problem on him I love Ron DeSantis I
think Rhonda Santos has done a fabulous
job as governor of Florida what he's
done has absolutely been incredible he
had a huge win last night
love a lot of other Republicans too who
who could run and so I'm just not
willing to I just think it's silly and
frivolous to to come out and make an
endorsement this early also
if Trump
manages to be able to run and clear the
field
then it's pointless to to play this
horse race game
and if Trump can't clear the field
if other people run against him or if he
doesn't run at all
then it's also pointless to jump on
board with the candidate right now
because that that means that everyone's
going to get in if Trump is not clearly
clearing the field
you're for sure going to get
DeSantis but think about all the other
people who have run for president who
could run for president again Tim Scott
has his publisher said he was running
for president remember that Nikki Haley
is clearly intimating
she would run for president Ted Cruz was
the number two guy last time he could
mount a very credible campaign Josh
Hawley has intimidated that he might run
Rand Paul could easily run I mean I just
think it'll be everybody
I think everybody will jump into that
race
so what happened last night
what do we blame
do we blame voter fraud
and rigging and shenanigans
not saying there's no role for that and
that could be playing out a little bit
especially in Arizona
and
I think it could be playing out less
from the batches of ballots coming in in
the middle of the night and more from
the look at this they've turned election
day into election season and people were
voting in Pennsylvania in September
before they realized that that John
Federman doesn't have a properly
functioning brain and that is and
there's ballot harvesting in a lot of
states and there's all sorts of and
there's all sorts of Corrupt Practices
yeah that does play a role and
Republicans need to get serious about
tightening that up and you don't need to
be on an election denying conspiracy
theorists to say that two months of
voting it favors Democrats and it's
wrong and it has no place in a proper
Republic and we need to get rid of it
Republicans need to stop just talking
about the fixing the fringes of these
electoral problems and get down and say
no early voting except for rare
exceptions no mail-in ballots except for
rare exceptions
people vote on Election Day we get the
results by night time okay that would be
good but but I don't blame election
fraud for the Republican weak
performance do I blame Trump
uh some of the Trump picks were pretty
bad but again you know I'm not even
willing to blame him too much for Oz I
think Oz is a total loser but David
McCormick who is the chief rival to Oz
and he was more The Establishment pick
David McCormick it was a socially
liberal hedge funder who wrote an amicus
brief to the Supreme Court on the
obergefell case and who is vocally in
favor of gay marriage and
it was I think he wrote an amicus brief
he was very very uh strongly in favor of
gay marriage and you know he he's not
exactly a till of the hunt Okay he was
not the it was not much more
conservative than Dr Oz and then Kathy
Barnett people felt couldn't make a
credible general election play
and they may have been right about that
she was the conservative in the race
so again you blame Trump for the Oz
endorsement okay but
would McCormick have done much better
I'm not totally convinced of that maybe
he would have but I'm not totally
convinced of that
and I think a lot of people who just
hate Trump are looking at this as an
excuse to attack Trump
that said Trump's record last night just
wasn't that great so it does hurt his
presidential prospects and and I think
people are going to
are going to cool on him just as a
result of it do you blame Biden because
Biden's doing such a great job no I
obviously I think that's insane do you
blame Roe v Wade the overruling of Roe v
Wade no I don't think that really played
any role in the race at all I don't see
that reflected in the polls uh you know
I I think that's kind of silly but one
place that people are not really talking
about and it goes a long way to
explaining why Republicans couldn't
quite put it over the edge in New York
why they couldn't really get it done in
Pennsylvania why nothing really happened
in California why Florida was just so
overwhelmingly Republican
why Texas had an extremely good night
for republicans and that is that people
have voted with their feet I'm one of
the people who voted with my feet I
moved out of new Cellini's hellscape of
California came to the free state of
Tennessee which is fabulous and a lot of
other people did that to Tennessee and
Texas and especially Florida but one of
the consequences of voting with your
feet is then you don't vote at The
Ballot Box in the state that you left
and it becomes harder for Republicans to
win so that's another macro trend of the
night that you can't just blame on Trump
or just give credit to some other
candidate for you have to say that's a
macro Trend in politics where it's yes
Republicans are going to do better in
the red States the red states are going
to get redder but that means the blue
states are going to get Bluer and it's
gonna be harder to have those purple
kinds of wins now I mentioned Texas I
mentioned Beto O'Rourke got destroyed
and usually I say okay let's take the
high road let's not rub it in anybody's
face but Beto he just bothers me okay
and so Alex Stein who has become one of
the absolute top trolls in America and
he's just he just seems you know
completely uh Unleashed and like a dog
with a bone and he I had him on the show
you know he just does things that are so
vulgar and mean and you just say I could
never do that well anyway he did it to
baitone it was very very funny
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you feel guilty about the money how
are you going to protect trans kids by
cutting off their genitals how does that
protect trans kids beta
beta how does that protect trans kids
beta
how are you protecting trans kids by
cutting off their genitals let's do it
that's all right baby you know you're
gonna lose beta this is how many losses
in a row how many more losses are you
gonna take let's move forward
how many more losses are you gonna take
you're gonna where's your campaign money
going
beta are you pointing out to this
failure are you gonna quit after you
fail today
yeah
they know do you feel guilty that you're
a loser later
[Applause]
do you feel like a loser Beto
you know the the election night it was a
little bit I just feel like I'm getting
a little sick you know I just I was so
excited I thought I was going to be
popping champagne and now I'm feeling
just a little down you know like I've
got I'm just just a little worn down in
that video of Alex Stein just yelling at
Beto and calling him a loser and asking
if he feels bad for wasting millions of
dollars on another failed campaign it's
just like a nice bowl of chicken soup
you know it's just like a nice warm
broth I just think
and then people are trying to pull Alex
Stein away and pull you know kind of hit
him in the head with with signs but he's
just kind of a big belligerent madman
and so he doesn't even care he just
doesn't just a dog with a bone doesn't
even stop beta you're a loser you want
to chop off kids genitals why are you
such a loser beta so it was a nice after
the kind of headache and aches and pains
of election night kind of set in that's
just a nice little
nice little bit of chicken soup are you
still giving your money
to woke razor companies that hate your
beliefs and see masculinity as toxic and
think that you should teach your
daughter to shave her beard there is
A Better Way Jeremy's razors are 100
real and 100 woke free the premium matte
tungsten handle has more heft than the
left the razor head pivots without
caving and has six blades that are
sharper than truth who writes this stuff
those other razor companies keep virtues
signaling to the totalitarian left and
using your money to do it you don't have
to let them when you buy Jeremy's razors
you are not just making Jeremy richer
you're making the woke left poorer 75
000 people have already made the switch
go to Jeremy's razors.com to get 40 off
your Founders serious shave kit today
that's Jeremy's razors.com Jeremy's
razors shut up
and shave
okay I've got to get to a little
non-election news I've got to get to the
really important stuff okay
really important news like how Jennifer
Lopez is now Jennifer Affleck
did you know this is a
is a New York Times essay
on why it matters that J Lo is now JF
I'm not joking and I actually agree with
the writer
Jennifer weiner
it does matter it actually does matter
that Jennifer Lopez is calling herself
Jennifer Affleck
Jennifer Lopez was asked about this she
said of course I changed my name it's
romantic and traditional now this lady
who wrote wrote the op-ed says that it's
cringy such a long long I don't
recommend that you read this entire
entire article but she says it's cringy
and Peak patriarchy and says Ms Affleck
by the way she's not mishap like she's
Mrs Affleck Miz is a feminist prefix
invented in the 1970s miss or misses
those are the proper terms so Mrs
Affleck maybe surrendering to the power
of love with this for fourth marriage
but given the cringy history behind the
practice a woman doesn't take her
husband's last name a woman taking her
husband's last name feels to me like a
submission a gesture that doesn't say I
belong with him so much as I belong to
him
and at this fraught moment for feminism
in America a woman like the former
Jennifer Lopez deciding to change her
name feels especially dispiriting
okay well yes in part it is a submission
yeah it is a wife submitting to her
husband
and in in turn the husband is called to
love his wife and the two are not
separate and it's not this domineering
and relationship where you've got a
master and a slave but it's it's two
people becoming one flesh that's at
least the idea again she mentions fourth
marriage and all these craziness in
Hollywood so
I'm just speaking in in principle about
marriage and a wife taking her husband's
name
but the reason this is such a stupid
essay
the reason it's such a stupid
point that the left makes that women
shouldn't take their husbands last names
is because
inevitably a woman is going to have a
Man's last name
a woman will either have her husband's
last name or her father's last name
but either way
the patriarchy wins
and if you're in a marriage it seems
kind of weird for the wife to have her
father's last name
because marriage is when people leave
their mothers and their fathers and they
come together a man and a woman come
together and become one flesh
and the man is the head of the household
and so it would stand a reason that the
man takes that the woman takes the
husband's last name if the man took the
wife's last name that would be weird
because then he would have her father's
last name and that just gets very very
confusing and complicated now you might
say well Michael what about the case
where a feminist has a child and the
feminist
does not take her husband's last name
and the feminist gives her daughter
her last name and then the daughter gets
married and she doesn't have her
father's last name she got her mother's
last name well that's true but hey
you just go back up one generation
guess who's last guess whose name the
feminist has
well no the feminist says her mom's like
well guess who has guess whose name and
at a certain point you go up the line
enough you're going to get to a fella
and so really what this is is not an
attack on the patriarchy or whatever
this is an attack on family
it's an attack on marriage itself which
is what the left is always after and
it's a sort of a stupid frivolous attack
now speaking of
transitions
this turned out to be a big issue I
think in the 2022 midterms I think it's
turned out to be a big issue even before
that going back to the Glenn young race
in Virginia
The Establishment Republicans
think that transiting the kids is a
sideshow it's a fake issue it's
contentious it's culture where they
should avoid it Dr Oz doesn't really
talk about it that the establishment
kind of hack Rhino candidates don't
really talk about it
you know who does talk about it Rhonda
Santos you know who does talk about it
Glenn Younkin you know who does talk
about it the conservative Republicans
who do very well
this is backed up by polls so a recent
poll found that more than 70 percent of
American voters in the 2022 midterms say
said that they are not likely to vote
for a candidate who supports allowing
minors to undergo gender transition
procedures sexual genital mutilation
nearly 80 percent of Independents and 43
percent of Democrats
joined the Republicans in opposing
candidates who support allowing
kids to transition transiting the kids
that's a huge number
obviously yeah basically all the
Republicans are on board eighty percent
of Independence that's bad news for
Democrats 43 of Democrats are with the
conservatives on this
so if you're just looking at those
numbers the GOP going into the midterms
should have been hammering this issue
not as a sideshow as a matter of justice
but also as a as an important political
matter this is a uniting good serious
important political issue
and by the way an analysis of voter
registration done by the AP in June
found that more than one million voters
across 43 States especially in the
suburbs where the swing voters often
sway the election results switched to
the GOP over the last year
one of the issues that's driving that
yes it's the misery index yes it's
inflation yes it's the economy but one
of the issues is this Insanity where
Democrats are chopping off kids genitals
so Republicans I think
failed to deal with that as well
it was a bit of a rough
night and it's it's hard to figure out
exactly what the takeaway is now I will
say
I try not to make predictions you'll
notice I usually do not make these firm
predictions about election night in fact
in as much as I did make predictions I
said You know guys I actually don't
think we're going to really win
Pennsylvania I don't think mastriano is
going to win I don't think John Federman
is or I rather I don't think Dr Oz is
going to beat fetterman I think
fetterman's going to be an upset I did
predict that Sean Patrick Maloney the
head of the D Triple C would lose in New
York's 17th congressional district he
would lose to the Republican Mike Lawler
I was right about that one too so I made
I made very
particular predictions where I felt
that the evidence was relatively clear I
did not make Grand sweeping predictions
and even other than you know maybe
advertising copy for the election show I
didn't say you know it's guaranteed
we're gonna have a red tsunami I'm gonna
be drinking leftist tears all night I
tempered expectations because I said you
know there's going to be some questions
people have been voting since September
there's lots of there's some not great
candidates out there and uh so I just
think as Drew claven says
you can't predict the future the future
is the future that's that's why it is
the future and so there is this funny
thing that goes on which is that the
pundits and the prognosticators
who make it their job to say I know
exactly what's going to happen on
Election night and they get all the
predictions wrong then the next day they
come out and they tell you precisely why
their predictions precisely why things
happened as they did happen and they
kind of ignore the fact that their
predictions were all wrong that happens
across the aisle and it happens all the
time with political pundits being a
political pundit is never having to say
that you're sorry
especially if you're the kind that just
tries to predict every single race and
so you're going to see a ton of people
today say well this is exactly why the
Republicans didn't do very well and
you're going to see a coincidence here
that the reasons why the Republicans
didn't do very as well as they were
supposed to is going to totally line up
with all of the pundits priors it's it's
going to affirm every premise that the
pundits had going in even if those
premises did not result in accurate
predictions for election night and
that's just what happens that's just
politics but but I've got a less popular
but I think more accurate take which is
there are a lot of factors here and you
can't just blame it on the fraud and you
can't just blame it on Trump and you
can't just blame it on
early voting and you can't just blame it
on Roe v Wade and you can't just you
can't just
there's a lot going on especially when
you look at two races you look at JD
Vance and Blake Masters
JD Vance and Ohio Black Masters running
for Senate in Arizona
they ran the same campaign they're
basically the same candidate they've got
the same background they've got the same
backers they ran on the same platform
JD wins Blake very very likely will lose
or it's just very unclear at least at
the moment
why is that well Ohio and Arizona are
different that's part of it
there's just a lot there's just a lot in
there and so what what you're going to
see now is the battle over what happened
and the battle over what happened is
nothing more than a proxy for the battle
for 2024. when I say the election is
dead long live the election this is not
the second day of counting the votes of
election day 2022. this is the first day
of the 2024 Republican presidential
primary and so all of the commentary
that you're going to be seeing today is
a facade a thinly veiled facade for a
campaign for one candidate or another in
2024 and because I actually have not
picked a candidate and I'm not endorsing
you know certainly not at this stage in
a presidential primary that's why I am
just trying to present all of these
sides and all of these uh all of these
factors that went into the midterms
last night although I am I am very
interested in hearing from you as well
and what you think happened in what you
were seeing in your polling places I
mean you the listeners to this show
or spread not just all around the
country but all around the world
we know that people all around the world
are watching the American elections as
well most of the people here at the
daily wire have coincidentally just been
overseas in Europe or the Middle East
within the past month and we know that
that people overseas everywhere follow
the American elections but especially
for those of you who are listening from
the United States right now what did you
see in your Precinct at your polling
place with your candidate with the with
the Republican Congressional candidate
in your District
some races that we thought we were going
to win my friend Beau Heinz was running
North Carolina he lost Lauren bobert
really really on the ropes Republican
Congressman another friend of mine in
Colorado so what happened what did you
see who and especially as everyone is
just looking to be so vindictive the
next morning
who do you blame let me know you can let
me know on Twitter or in email or
whatever comments and mailbag but you
can especially let me know in the member
block of this show the rest of the show
continues now it is woke Wednesday we've
got an ad from fetterman that my
producers tell me is one that I actually
didn't play I haven't seen this one so I
guess they just want to rub salt in the
wounds of Senator fetterman coming out
uh you don't want to miss this part of
the show
if you're not a member click on the link
in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]